I am sort of interested in Maine because
I have it as a three to one split and
week we can go to the map if you want
Pat uh I have made as the three two one
split 3 for Hillary uh one for Donald
and I'm also interested in Pennsylvania
of course which were closing at eight
o'clock Kiki state the the default would
be that this goes blue uh if it goes red
it's not good at all for Hillary Clinton
right that that would be a really big
problem for Hillary Clinton uh also
Michigan is closing at eight o'clock
Michigan is a place historically
Democratic both Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump have been there in the last
week suggesting she was worried about it
and he thought maybe he could strike so
I'm interested in seeing Michigan at
eight o'clock uh and then other than
that i'm curious about texas and by how
much Donald Trump will win I I of course
have Texas for Donald Trump but would it
be 54 to 46 or would it be more like
6040 I'm very interested in the turn
Texas blue movement I don't know about
you been no very much interested and I
I'd love the data that was coming out of
texts that showed a a generational
divide older conservatives were locked
in for Donald Trump younger
conservatives were absolutely not locked
in for Donald Trump yeah so depending on
that number split that we see the
percentage play we can get an idea of
what's the future of of Texas no doubt
and I think when we also look everybody
we don't have to have this it's election
night for 2016 we're not really going to
have a serious conversation about 20 20
right now but Georgia is an interesting
state also when you look at changing
demographics and what's going on there
although today absolutely it will go for
Donald Trump right now Georgia 7230 in
favor of trump based on what has been
counted uh but i think that there's a
very interesting story to be told in
florida uh and i'm sorry in georgia and
florida is is getting very interesting
tonight because as we've said if Hillary
Clinton wins Florida this thing is
effectively over it's not mathematically
over but these results are sort of
correlated and they depend on each other
even though we think about it is 51
individual elections these the or 53 if
you consider Nebraska and main in in
their congressional districts but these
are related so
you're now going to go back to the map
we have our eight o'clock closings
coming up as you see here Texas Oklahoma
Kansas Missouri Illinois North and South
Dakota Michigan Tennessee Mississippi
Alabama Pennsylvania Massachusetts
Connecticut Rhode Island main Florida
Maryland and New Jersey let's see what
we have number one we are ready to say
that Hillary Clinton has taken Illinois
for 20 electoral votes that is indeed
the way I had it on my map New Jersey is
being called for Hillary Clinton that is
14 electoral votes there uh we can also
say at this point that good old
Commonwealth of Massachusetts where I
voted and Pat voted and Rachel voted and
been voted is crediting 11 electoral
votes to Hillary Clinton and in Maryland
10 electoral votes also to Hillary
Clinton are any of these surprising
absolutely not at all if they were not
for Hillary Clinton we would be very
very concerned we can also put Rhode
Island's for electoral votes squarely on
the blue side as well as Delaware's
three electoral votes and Washington
DC's three electoral votes for Hillary
Clinton that gets us to 68 2 24 in favor
of Hillary Clinton for Donald Trump
picking up as expected seven electoral
votes in Oklahoma no surprise there I
would be curious as to the margin
Tennessee is also going for Donald Trump
as is Mississippi and we are starting to
get a picture of how this is going to
come together now unfortunately it is
too close to call in Florida
Pennsylvania and New Hampshire exactly
as we thought it might be yeah what
numbers do we have in those states well
let's see if we can check out the
Guardians current reporting on that
Florida right now about a 1.6 percentage
point lead yeah up for Hillary Clinton
and we have new hampshire where is New
Hampshire right now currently not able
to find new hampshire here on my little
list uh it is slightly blue according to
the Guardian which certainly tells us
something and North Carolina now at the
latest
a five point four percent lead for
Hillary Clinton with her over 51% now it
is still very early in North Carolina
but if that momentum continues building
been I think that that would be a big
big deal Hillary Clinton a seven point
two percent lead in North Carolina
according to CNN five point four percent
lead according to the Guardian know
growing now to an eight point two
percent lead in North Carolina for
Hillary Clinton according to the
Guardian so a lot is happening here but
officially 68 to 48 right now give me a
sense been any thoughts about any of
these results so far uh nothing
surprising yet except for New Hampshire
to see how the Senate race is splitting
with the presidential race um I i think
the Senate candidate there started
distancing herself from Donald Trump
soon enough to actually salvage her
campaign right so we may see a prayer a
president that we may see the electoral
votes go toward Clinton and the Senate
go to the Republican Party um but that's
the only thing surprising out of those
states so far yeah uh we are going to
continue following these small new up
these these increases in the amount of
uh votes being reported in some of these
major major races uh that's the current
picture right now so to get everybody up
to speed of the states that have closed
but we have not yet been able to
announce a winner we are looking at new
hampshire Virginia South Carolina
nobody's putting it officially in the
Trump camp yet even where we know it
eventually will be a Georgia and Florida
North Carolina Ohio main Connecticut
Pennsylvania uh DC has has been called
up Michigan Illinois so many states that
have officially closed so far but we
have not yet heard anything about from
any of the major networks from the
Guardian from The Associated Press etc
uh we know that reporting is done
differently in different states so the
fact that it wasn't instantly announced
at eight o'clock doesn't really tell us
too much necessarily no no it does and
also I found this out i'm coming from
ABC with some exit polling voters said
that they were bothered and this is
some preliminary uh exit polling from
ABC News saying that they were bothered
by Trump's treatment of women mom more
than by Clinton's emails uh however
state-by-state the numbers range widely
with more voters in Arizona and Texas
bothered by the emails obviously that
you can expect that so I think you'll
see that division go clearly on partisan
lines no doubt about it and you know it
when I was looking at some of the early
exit polling results things like them
the plurality of voters want change it
was something like thirty six percent
yeah that's true but altogether the
majority wanted something else right so
I think that sometimes when you look at
these a polling exit polling results
when you've basically got a two
candidate race the fact that you might
have a plurality of voters wanting one
thing yeah that is not the most
important thing because you still have a
majority of voters wanting some other
combination of things yeah which may not
lead you to one can deter the other
that's I think we have to be super
careful with these exit polls ya know
same phenomena we saw within the
Republican Party I'm when they were
asked after the primaries do they would
they want someone else they say yes we
want someone else but still Donald Trump
ended up with the plurality right
because each of those Republicans
thought of a different person exam they
were talking about who is that someone
else uh that we want at eight-thirty we
will officially have Arkansas closing I
think it will come as no surprise to
anybody that that is obviously going to
be going in favor of Donald Trump now
there's something very very interesting
going on right now in Ohio with twenty
four percent of the ballots counted in
ohio and i don't i'm taking it easy here
because i don't want to overstate the
importance of this this is only twenty
four percent now twenty six percent
hillary clinton is ahead in ohio
significantly okay we don't even have to
get to the numbers but with twenty six
percent of the votes counted hillary
clinton is well ahead in ohio I don't
think I need to overstate the importance
of Ohio for Donald Trump right I never
even included it in Hillary Clinton's
path to victory if Hillary Clinton is
able to do something in Ohio that ends
this race yeah that's not where we are
right now I'm not sure has there been a
Republican candidate who's won in the
last 30 40 years without taking didn't
take Ohio that's an interesting
Republican is ever
on the whole presidency without taking
Ohio is that I need for Republicans yet
well Trump's able to win this thing he
would have to take a lo hi Oh along with
it while all right we'll listen I think
that what we should do is we should take
a few more calls and if we want did I
don't know Rachel was going to help us
with the calls or what we're doing but
um we will take calls at 6 1 7 830 4750
and then if at some point we have a lull
then we can get to that question of
worst-case scenarios under Hillary and
Trump which uh you you said we could
talk about together which which I think
would be great to talk